hey YouTube long time no no talk uh
because I've been banned here now
technically the show is unbanned but we
have two strikes on the account and
we've been told that we're very likely
to get a third one if we do anything
that you know is remotely fun so uh you
may not know this we're still streaming
every day on Rumble and I would love to
see that subscriber number right up
there wherever it is I don't have the
best peripheral vision go down to zero
and uh just rack up there on Rumble so
it's still every weekday Monday through
Friday 10 a.m Eastern it's cultural
appropriation month which we would not
dare risk doing on YouTube so until we
come back here to stream which maybe
never we're still figuring it out huh
consider the mass Back The Exodus right
now the red tide has been parted Rumble
10 a.m Eastern Monday through Friday we
are still streaming just not going to
see you here for a little while I think
I need to fix this
the thing because I can't
did you say something
[Music]
what I know
yesterday
[Music]
before I know
there's nothing
[Music]
that's what I know
foreign